overall the commission's report come
Greece has taken the necessary actions
to achieve its commitments for meet 2019
this progress will allow our deputy fine
ministers to approve at vwg and the FSF
Board of Directors the policy contingent
depth relief measures as usual the
decision is subject to the completion of
national procedures these that measures
concern the transfer to Greece of
profits made by the central banks on
Greek government bonds the so-called SNP
alpha and the reduction to zero of the
step up interest margin on certain EFSF
loans we also looked at the post program
surveillance for Cyprus in Spain we
commended both countries for their
strong economic performance and
encourage them to keep addressing the
remaining imbalances and vulnerabilities
of their financial sectors yesterday we
have reached an agreement in principle
on all elements related to the SM reform
subject to the conclusion of national
procedures
these included the backstop guideline
the pricing guideline three board of
governors resolutions the amended
guideline on precautionary financial
assistance in terms of reference and
explanatory note on the single limb
collective action closes the so-called
[ __ ] that's why we're starting only now
so the president will report on the
meeting from last night and then the
others about Greece I have to say that I
had on Tuesday a very positive meeting
with the finance minister Christos stai
chorus and that the country according to
our report is well on the road to
recovery
obviously as Mario say challenges remain
but government is strongly committed to
face these challenges
and also yesterday during the discussion
that we had in the Eurogroup the
minister was very clear about these
commitments in there we had an
interesting and good discussion on the
draft budgetary plans not so much on the
single draft budgetary plan of the 19
countries in this case I present the
opinions adopted by the Commission but
on the general fiscal policies and I am
convinced that we need more than ever to
have coordinated and differentiated
fiscal policies we are not 19 separate
economies we are a monetary and economic
Union and I think we should work in the
next year's to build on this concept I
repeated yesterday what is our thinking
as a commission that the perspective
should be in the future to have the
integration of the SEM in the EU legal
framework this remains from the
Commission point of view a goal
the agreement in principle yesterday was
important for us because it covers all
the elements that we have discussed many
times in the Euro group at these press
conferences it relates to the bog
backstop for the SRB a stronger role for
the ESM and huge economic adjustment
programs together with the Commission
and it's very good that we have an
agreement how we will cooperate in the
future the memorandum of cooperation was
mentioned by the Commissioner and we
reviewed our financial instruments in
particular as a precautionary credit
lines and all that is important to make
the use easier and more efficient and
that can help to prevent small problems
from becoming big problems given the
commitment of the government to
implement growth friendly reforms and to
stick to the agreed fiscal targets laid
the basis for us to disperse seven
hundred and sixty-seven million euro to
Greece importantly this is not a new ESM
loan this is a grant a transfer which is
much better than a loan because it
doesn't have to be repaid and there's no
interest on it so this really helps some
Greek debt sustainability that's why it
was agreed a few years ago to do this so
and it will continue over the next three
years